[Music]
welcome to this episode of click to
deploy
a series where we show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from the google
cloud marketplace
in this episode we'll be reviewing how
to set up a lamp stack through the
marketplace
lamp stands for linux operating system
apache
http server mysql database management
system
and php programming language it's a set
of open source software used to build
web applications
we'll start by searching for lamp stack
in the gcp marketplace
there are a few options from different
vendors each with their own version of
linux
differing security models as well as
support models
for this demo we'll choose the google
click to deploy option
let's do a quick run-through of the
summary of the deployment
this specific deployment will be
launched on a single vm of my size
choosing
as always the pricing information
displays a high-level estimate of
charges
once we customize our deployment we'll
receive a more detailed breakdown
let's start the launch
similar to many marketplace deployment
options we'll pick a name
and the zone in which we'll deploy i'll
stick with the default name and zone
us west2b we can also continue with the
default machine type which is an e2
small
having two vcpus and two gigs of memory
let's keep the default for boot disk and
networking options
we'll end with making sure our vm can
accept http and https traffic from the
internet
[Music]
before you deploy you can see a final
estimate of costs with the custom
options you configured for deployment
by clicking details you can expand for
an itemized cost breakdown
keep in mind these costs may not include
charges for networking and monitoring
we'll launch and give it a minute to
spin up
[Music]
let's take a look at our deployment
information
clicking the site address will display
our default lamp web application
this is just the landing page for apache
one of the first suggested next steps is
to change the mysql temporary password
so we can do that by using the
phpmyadmin web interface that's provided
to us
now that we're more secure let's go back
and change our landing page to something
custom
we can ssh into the vm and act as the
root user to customize the index.html
[Music]
page
[Music]
we can refresh our ip url and now we
have our very simple
yet customized lamp stack deployed at
the click of a button
using the google cloud marketplace
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the gcp
marketplace and deploy this solution on
your own
thanks for watching
you